Hello Freak bitches.
So where do you go from here?
Besides suing the fuck out of Google?
Google.
Just give him some money to send of,
shut him out.
Do you want to go through what a lawsuit,
like what if they came to you with a settlement?
Would you just take it and shut your mouth?
I really want somehow for them to address it,
but uh,
I,
I don't know how it is.
Well,
even if they,
if you lose in court,
will they address it?
They'll probably say,
you know,
all the,
we support the court,
we disagree with the rulings and we still support gender equality and Blam Blam
Blam blam
yeah,
I mean,
I think part of it is that there's currently an asymmetry,
so maybe Google is acting in their best interest to act the way that they are
because they think that,
you know,
there's all these activists that are trying to attack Google that only if they
don't fit this.
Sorry.
Are there are a lot of activists that are attacking Google in that regard.
Yeah.
And you know,
we even see that there's now a potential class action lawsuit against Google
about war,
uh,
gender pay disparity.
And so like they just are looking for anything.
And if we say that,
you know,
if there's only incentive coming from one side,
then they're only going to push farther and farther to that side.
And this gender pay disparity is just a involving similar jobs
yet.
So they claim that it's the same job,
although at least when Google was doing their own internal analysis,
which they've been doing for years,
they show that there's no disparity once you control for preparing for
performance.
And so it's really unclear and
but you control for performance performance tends to favor males.
Maybe I if,
if that's what they're showing that there is sound.
Sorry,
gender disparity.
If you just look at aggregate.
Yeah,
look at this one in 100 million chance alleged gender pay gap at Google is
random says class action lawyer.
Oh Jesus.
Class action lawyer says that in the articles written by a Czech fake news.
Fake News.
You're not going to get me.
You fucks.
I didn't.
One thing is I don't think that they really have Google's internal data,
so there's no way for them to say whether or not it's based on the performance
liquid there.
They're saying here,
you know,
um,
uh,
notices seeking women currently or formerly employed at Google for possible
inclusion in a planned class action lawsuit.
First of all,
people hear that and they're like,
we're going to get paid.
Well,
God says law,
right?
I mean that's just,
you're playing on human instincts when you seek out people that may have been
employed for a possible inclusion in a class action lawsuit.
That's not saying that they weren't wronged because I don't,
obviously,
I don't know,
several dozen came forward in a matter of weeks.
That's a pretty high level of dissatisfaction.
Says James Feinberg.
No,
it's not.
No.
There's thousands of people who've worked there and a couple does and came
forward.
That's not a high level of satisfaction.
How many people have been employed at Google that are no longer employed?
It's probably tens of thousands,
right?
Yeah.
There's 70,000 people working there.
And so for this guy to say,
that's a pretty high level of dissatisfaction when several dozen,
let's say three does and let's go crazy.
Let's say it's 40 people,
it's get nuts.
That's fucking nobody man yet.
Oh 70 women.
It's only because I heard from,
but wait a minute,
hurt from that.
Doesn't that you mean they might not even make sense?
That might not be a case for four people.
Four,
that's not a lot.
You fuck the class action.
I mean that's just,
this is,
this is a fucking ambulance chaser Chaser,
right?
I mean I'm not saying he's wrong,
I'm not saying there's not sexual discrimination,
but I'm saying like this is,
these articles are sneaky as fuck for people.
You got four people and I don't know how an individual would know whether or not
they're paid differently just based on their sex.
Right?
Because there's so many variables at play.
So you really have to look at the system as a whole because I mean there are
definitely some men that are paid less than the women too.
And I know for performance is like that.
The problem is when you control for performance,
if it turns out that men are being paid more than you have to figure out some
sort of way to justify that or you know like if men are being paid more when you
control for performance,
what is it that's causing the men to be paid more?
Why are they performing better?
Like is it the environment they feel more comfortable?
Is it lack of suppression that the women experience?
Like you said,
I guess when you look at the nationwide gender gap in pay where you know even
Obama has said 77 cents per dollar is too little,
but he's a silly person.
Like I shouldn't have done that.
Like he knows like when Obama said that he knows that that's not being honest
because you're talking about completely different jobs,
different choices for people don't know.
Okay,
let's just break that down real quick.
This,
this thing cause people repeated ad nauseum and it's just not true.
The gender pay gap of 77 cents to a dollar that a male makes is based on the
choices that people make as far as like what they do for a living.
It's based on the amount of hours that they work.
Men tend to work longer hours,
women tend,
especially if they get pregnant,
all those things are factored in.
That's where you get 77 cents on average for the dollar that the male makes.
What it implies,
and this is where it's disingenuous because it two people working side by side
doing the same job and the males getting 77 more a dollar for the woman's 77
cents.
That's not what the gender pay gap actually means.
And if Google is actually,
if someone is saying,
if there's a lawsuit that's saying that a man and a woman are doing the exact
same job
with the exact same performance and the woman is only getting 77 cents on the
dollar,
then you got a real issue.
Right?
Yeah.
And so it's often are,
uh,
that,
you know,
there's different hours worked and it doesn't even have to be that,
they work twice as many or 30% more.
It's sometimes if you just work,
you know,
44 hours a week versus 34 hours or something,
then there's a huge pay disparity.
Yeah.
And that's irrespective of what gender you have.
It's just,
yeah,
especially at Google,
there was so much time that was just,
you know,
replying to email and doing some base level stuff,
going to meetings and then you only had a little bit that was actually creative
and providing value to the company.
Really.
Yeah.
So it's really inefficient that regard.
Right.
And you know,
it's similar in a lot of companies too,
so,
and that creates some of this nonlinear,
uh,
benefits of working just a little more per week.
And we see this a lot in silicon valley where there's a lot of people right out
of college and they're willing to work a ton of time,
especially,
you know,
you can essentially live at Google.
So I mean,
yeah,
there's free food everywhere.
There's showers,
there's a gym,
the beds.
There's nap pods.
Pods.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.